hello and welcome to games spots now
playing of oh damn we're playing The
Witcher 3 wild Hunt I'm your host Daniel
DWI thank you so much for joining us
today on gamespot.com or if you're
watching our streams on twitch.tv or
YouTube uh we are doing something very
special today we're showing off the Xbox
One version of The Witcher 3 wild Hunt
um a game that if you've been following
gamespot's coverage of you know that we
are we're pretty hyped about in the
leadup to release and then our reviewer
Kevin vanard gave this game only the
ninth 10 out of 10 in Gamespot reviews
history l in almost 20 years of covering
video games so this is a very special
game um I'm going to be playing this
from the beginning so if you are looking
for a purely vanilla spoiler-free
experience um this might be for you but
what I will say is somebody who's
already played the first six hours of
this last month in CD project uh R in
Warsaw
the start of this game is not uh it's
the type of game that it's really when
you open up into the wider world that
you start getting into the nitty-gritty
spoiler stuff the start is basically the
same for everyone H and what I'll be
doing is when we play the prologue area
of the game which is the first two hours
of it h which is basically like an
extended tutorial for everyone and it's
uh it's takes part around a griffin
fight which has been highly publicized
by most of the gamees press over the
past six months um once we've done that
I'm not going to be diving into the main
quest I'm going to be purely sticking to
side quest so the initial part of this
will you know in terms of you wanting to
get a completely free version uh of it
not looking at any preview coverage then
by all means H don't check it out but I
uh I'm very sensitive to the how the
aspects of this game there will be
spoilery and I'll be uh keeping an eye
on that and staying clear of them all
right that's enough chitchat from the
Irish boy let's jump in we're going to
we're going to go full screen on this we
literally haven't even tested out this
bad boy so fingers crossed it all goes
wonderfully smoothly as I said this is
on the the Xbox One um uh so you're
going to get to enjoy the rescaled heads
up display part of this experience as
well as everything else oh yeah I want
to see that where is that barely
visible there you
go let's do
that okie
dokie I got it no one no one plug out
the console okay I see you gather before
me hungry
terrified clutching your babes to your
breast I'm going to be keeping pretty
silent during all these parts uh just to
let you know if you're watching this on
gamespot.com I'm also keeping an eye on
the chat room uh so if you guys have any
special requests especially when we get
to the open World part of the game I'll
be I'll be checking that out all right
shut up now you stand at the precipice
your kings have failed you so now you
turn to the gods and yet you do not
plead you do not kneel to dust your
heads with
Ash instead you wail why have the gods
forsaken
us we must look into the trials we
failed long ago in a Time past our world
intertwined with another through an
upheaval Scholars call the conjunction
of the
Spheres the gods allowed Unholy forces
to slip into our domain
The Offspring of that cataclysm was the
nefarious Force called
Magic yet we did not banish it instead
studying the V Arcane for our own power
and
wealth and the monsters at our door the
Unholy relics of this conjunction the
trolls the corpse eaters the werewolves
did we raise our swords against them or
have we laid this burden on others on
soall witchers yeah stray children
taught the ways of foul sorcery their
bodies mutated through Blasphemous
ritual Sanctified monsters though they
could not distinguish good from Evil the
flicker of humanity long extinguished
within
them yes their numbers have dwindled
through the years but a few still roam
our lands offering their bloody work for
coin to this day they shame us with
their very existence the north
bleeds flogged by War the battles are
the God's whip chastisement for our sins
and let us not forget the Terrace the
scourges from beyond our world the wild
Hunt rides the sky with every full moon
the the dark Raiders abduct our children
into lands unknown some say they Herald
a second
conjunction can we chart a course back
into the light will we find the strength
to banish the Mages from our kingdoms
unite around the warmth of the Eternal
fire now is the time of the sword and
axe none will fight this war in our
stead nigh is the time of M
and
disain oh man that was great uh that was
not in the build that I played in Warsaw
but that's a pretty good uh setup for
those who don't understand the uh the
world of The Witcher let me just make
sure first of all that we've got
subtitles turned on for all you
guys uh watching this bad boy yep all
right we're good I'm going to go for
Polish text Portuguese thre out I love
how English is on the left side and
polish is on the right it's like the
sliding scale of languages right right
there uh okay new
game these are the difficulty settings
so there's four of them just the story
no thanks story and
sword season demanding gamer man I kind
of feel like I want to go for this but
for the sake of the stream you can
change the difficulty setting at any
time so I'm just going to do this number
two
ah yeah why not
um so the simulate Wich or two save is
an interesting aspect of this H there's
a part again which we didn't cover in
our preview coverage where you basically
um there's a part where you you fill in
Story Part uh aspects I'm going to go
with on just so folks in the chat can
see what those decisions
are H this has been out for a while this
video this is the intro sequence uh with
uh one of the Guardian battles in
yennefer it's pretty cool so I'm not to
totally [__] de capitates a horse so
uh let's watch
it our
boy
as so for those in the chat wondering we
are streaming this in 720 uh this is the
Xbox One
version so uh yeah everything you're
seeing here because of the way we output
to the very streaming platforms it looks
better for the stream if we do it in 720
pure instead of forcing it
so I'm going to be keeping an eye on the
frame rate stuff from this uh side it's
going a little bit hit you here
actually this is all
pre-rendered you don't want to be
standing there yennifer
ah it's not a good way to
go
so for those of you who don't know the
story uh at least the prologue part of
this involves uh gal and his uh his
mentor from all those years ago um
hunting down their friend
yennefer uh but basically sort of the I
don't want to get into too much of it
because I know what happens I've played
the first couple of bits of this um but
that's what you're sort of task with at
the start of the game there is an area
before we get to the prologue part which
we never talked about in previews it's a
basically a tutorial part
um which we're about to dive into now so
what you've seen now is probably never
seen before we'll we'll have to
see oh I take it back it skipped that
part interesting huh
okay or has
it oh no here we
go oh
man you probably seen this
before
yeah yeah great the next gen
Wang AR you love when you just bathe
with a demonic
Lobster yeah so for those of you are
joining the stream like you are looking
for a spoiler-free
experience go back and play the with you
too you know I don't find that amusing
magic
crab that's the only crabs in this room
know what I'm saying it wasn't meant to
amuse but to prod you to hurry it's
midday
already you promised Siri you'd train
with her go before vessir BS her to
death with those
etchings
H looks like he baites with crabs all
the
time so this little area here is the
tutorial part it doesn't last too long
it's maybe about 20 minutes or so see
you
later and this takes place in Kor which
is the home of the witchers which if
you're familiar with the books or the
first two games you'd be more than
familiar with this isn't part of the
open world it is an area that we
apparently travel back to later in the
game as well um but it sort of acts as a
little sort of a introductory area
here looks good on Xbox One the frame
R's a little bit hitchy
but see what it's like when we get into
game
play yeah okay we get it she's naked
yeah all
right
all right here we
go let's uh let's see what it's all
about yep mini map in the top right
objective is directly underneath
it o mountain pass is beautiful as ever
there you go first thing geralt says in
the game is [__] you've seen it all
right left trigger does my Witcher
senses uh I think our friend Siri is
down there thinging away I'm just going
to get to
it you're running out of juice I know
you might bring me some more once you're
done training basically anything in the
game that's fir just like in which or
two we can just magic turn it off magic
turn it on
again
all right let's run
around oh same with
that unlock the
door
HRA I don't think there's anywh to fight
just about yet you can jump in The
Witcher 3
confirmed new aspect of the
series old witcher's fast asleep Siri's
disappeared somewhere of
course
guess she prefers practice to
Theory why time to wake up Master these
lessons so boring they put you to sleep
too damn it that taking notes on Ghouls
and Al ghouls wanted to rest this guy is
uh geralt's oh I forget his name right
now uh he's geralt's old Mentor and he's
currently training Siri who's the other
playable character in this game and her
stuff is basically like sort of tack the
P located in not in the open world in
sort of chapters that you flash to at
various points in the story how many
times do I have to tell her don't train
alone it only embeds your errors bring
our young damsel to the lower Courtyard
she wants to practice she'll get to
practice hooray what a perfect
opportunity for a tutorial uh don't get
mad at her don't get mad at her why the
hell not a whipper snapper refuses lot
of talking in uh The Witcher 3 for those
of you who haven't played the other
games it's sort of akin to Elder schs
games in which you are taking on quests
and fighting and whatnot but
like is not something to be taken like
conversations are not just a piece of
flavor to move on the dialogue it's Al
they're also used in the sort of uh hats
you decide to take both in terms of the
narrative and in terms of
like how quests progress
that's
impressive
wrong now I see why you were so eager to
practice
strike
who you're out in this circus
pouette wrong
footwork enough get down hey yeah so
some folks in the chat asking about
patches so the version that we reviewed
on PS4 had the day one patch
pre-installed uh for what I believe
this the pre or downloaded one for Xbox
one I don't think it has a day one patch
on it maybe for and we've also heard
that they might be pushing at a second
patch for the game on a bunch of
platforms so this is still I would say
that one of the aspects are trying to
address apparently far from some little
bugs are the frame rate stuff so well
yes but I don't think it'll be 100% fair
to say that this is the final version
but it's pretty much there no
excuse I'm sorry it won't happen
again you not enough Sorry's not good
enough you're going to read Ghouls and
Al ghouls in its entirety appendices
included yeah no please I'd rather clean
the Stables end of discussion come on
we'll practice with the others down
below shall We Run The
Walls yeah why not of course is a
Witcher School or an Elvin Bath
House teach me how to run and jump video
game maybe if you
fall so this stream's going to be about
2 hours long long we're going to see
I've already managed to get myself stuck
by something um he's a little bit Jeff
uh from GI bomb was talking to me about
this he's a little bit um idiosyncratic
when it comes to moving geralt around
works better during combat I'll say that
much some of the just exploring stuff
feels a little bit really weird or at
least on a controller the messing
keyboard stuff when I played it in more
seem to fit a bit
better Siri cut it out
pretty sure this is a
race I'm going to race her I'm going to
beat a child at a race that seems
fair a damn it maybe
not yeah who needs
ladders oh run into trouble oh yeah it's
way harder to control him on a
controller
yaa this
is
so this is 30 FPS on uh current gen
consoles if you got a beef beefy enough
rig you can get this B Bo Running on uh
60 frames a second on a
PC all I won the stupid
race
yeah sucking
kid that guy's not a very good Witcher
at
all anything to say for yourself young
lady I'm very sorry Uncle resir Young
Blood craves action I understand that
but when you fight a beast knowledge
counts as much as your silver sword at
the very least you you want to be able
to tell a ghoul from an owl ghoul by
markings like unto The panthera Tigress
that in deria dwells and by the sickly
paleness of its
Visage damn so you did read the chapter
still you should have asked if but you
were asleep Uncle
vmir so you did the reading why not
admit it right
off never pounce on an Advantage as soon
as it appears wait till it stands to
have maximum effect Uncle vas's words
well you're a quick study quick but
mischievous fine we' talked enough
geralt you're with me Lambert with
escoll s again good stop groaning and
grab a
sword all right this is the Combat
tutorial um basically vamir teaches
rathers the combat in The Witcher wild
taunt which is not as difficult and
certainly not as idiosyncratic
as uh yeah let's do it work on the
basics as The Witcher two but it still
involves a couple of different systems
working in tandem uh notably blocking
attacking with your sword and then using
your magic skills as well so this is a
pretty much a little primer about how
the magic works there are multiple ways
the magic works your
sword or signs rather I should refer to
the Mouse um and whatnot all
right so he's got two swords steel and
silver one is predominantly used for
quick monsters one of the other is
predominantly used for
humans stries now give it all your X for
light attack y for that a strong
blow is Dodge you can do that in a bunch
of directions
remember they slow it down a bit there
that pauses for the benefit of the
player
there hit Meir
yeah so you can free attack you can like
walk around this way if you click in or
on or on the stick it targets somebody
you don't have do that
sword am I suppos to uh left trigger
block dumy pretend now live later repost
strike Counter
Strike Counter
Strike just before they attack you can
sort of get a little little Muay Thai
kick in
there what now that's only a tap take
that where the other ones a hold s your
jugul
the thing that's interesting about the
Witcher is that it's actually it's
mostly when it comes down to them like
mob fighting that it gets the most
interesting we're using your magic is is
pretty important as well uh so there are
five main signs this quen it's the first
one basically gives you sort of a quen
is sometimes called Shi Shield carefully
to see yeah that's what's up you're
basically like Master Chief
bubble cast geralt I want to see SM igny
is the fire damage one it's your
Fireball situation if not for the quen
sign I'd be a flame by
now all geralt come
on and next up is
Ard it's kind of like a force push I
guess see that Siri AR will knock anyone
or anything off b super good for
physics fun
and then I hate this
feeling ax is the one that eventually
lets you like straight up control
people's
minds it's just disorientating him here
but later on you can use it uh to get
people to fight alongside you and
whatnot show
heral oh and then this is a this is a
really cool one especially when you got
a bunch of people this is
uh Bas slows down
time
never don't worry Siri and then he's
also got grenades because why the hell
not so eat
grenade eat magic
grenade
oh and then because this is a Call of
Duty video game I have to throw grenades
at um things in the distance so if you
hold down Orbee I believe yeah yeah you
get a little
little bit of
a see the sword all right my sword
enough continue training at
will
oh so the crossbow comes later um those
those looking to know where the crossbow
is it comes during the next tutorial
part where you fight the Griffin which
is actually probably close to the end of
this stream like we're only going to
stream for 2 hours is the the hard limit
we've been put on it and we've got
minutes left the prolog area of this uh
game is is like a smaller version of an
open world and it culminates in a
griffin fight soon as back the crossbow
is generally used for like you can use
it to attack smaller uh enemies as well
but um it's also used against larger
enemies especially flying ones to get
them down on the ground um so there's
still a lot of stuff to talk about
there's the potions for instance we
still haven't touched upon uh which are
different to The Witcher two because
they're sort of a little bit less
restrictive they fill up differently the
way you meditate and whatnot is
different cuz it's an open world game
you can get into fights anywhere they're
sort of they're a little bit less uh
restrictive on that what's up with this
dummy what's going
on what
then what's in the
dummy what's in the
dummy oh
[__]
IED this and white
wolf
no
damn people fre freaking out in the chat
that's the wild Hunt right there uh
don't worry about it though it's just a
[__] bad dream you know when you have
a bad dream and it's a
tutorial it's one of
those all right so we're on the way to
Vima at the moment um we're going to go
to the town of white Orchard on the way
we're still hunting for yenifer of
course had a nightmare
about take forever to
explain yeah probably da Some Way El was
serious she was a kid and then this
[__] ice boat turned
up H let's tell him started in the guest
room at K Morin I was relaxing in the
tub and next to me Tris yennefer funny
isn't it she's never been there seemed
so real in my dream though was she
nagging you about
something true to life
indeed so when I played this game before
last month uh throughout my time with
it the dialogue was just
fantastic then we trained consistently
not just between the two of these like
all of thect new people you meet
returning characters all that stuff it's
an absolute dreamid who were faster
stronger enjoy the chat none had her
character
Sunrise didn't end well did it your
dream no the wild Hunt appeared attacked
Siri I couldn't move stood there like a
stump I wouldn't worry too much if
people if they're worried about like
ruining this for themselves this is the
tip of a very very big
Iceberg you're going to B through all
this stuff in the first two hours of the
game and you're going to keep playing
for you know plus 100 more so and this
is the same for everyone it's the
moments where you have those like really
interesting unique experience that
you'll probably cherish there didn't
Overlook anything we were meant to meet
in Willoughby that's what she wrote
meanwhile one army or another burned the
village to the ground all we can do is
follow her Trail so stop talking for a
minute and give me the
letter how about that lilac and
gooseberries does smell of lilac and
gooseberries going to read it not sniff
it they must meet
soon willough be near
viima the is a big time nothing else to
guide us there was it in boat witches or
just two what's this postcript I still
have the
Unicorn that's so
good
uh yeah that's private that's private
very private aha I understand at least I
think I do maybe not entirely but
perhaps that's for the best back on
topic how's it look how far behind
yennefer are we two or 3 days tra sex on
a unicorn you should talk to our friend
geralt Rivia the first time I played
this part it reminded me not to be too
overly gushing about this game but the
part that happens um in a minute or two
after this little fight um reminded me
of walking out of the uh Vault 101 and
fall
out uh this is the first sord of the
monster battle just to get used to
fighting mobs I
guess so again we are playing on the
second of four
difficulties white stick is what I can
use to focus on one
enemy let's get some magic in here let's
get igny
up Le
ghoul my stamina is probably dumping it
a bit all right come
on so right stick again is what you use
to focus on one of
them probably blocking too
much I can Parry this guy as
well uh let's use
hard yeah eat a
ghoul adrenaline points certain
abilities right yeah so it's like rage I
guess an armies pass all those guys are
gone let's go you can regenerate Your
vitality by eating or drinking or by
meditating for at least an hour uh my
Vitality is not too bad at the moment
um not sure if I have any
food this song I was playing in my head
for days after tell you about this
sorcerer I knew couldn't stop playing
this game the music in this game is
fantastic all right and uh we're into
The Witcher 3 wild
H
BL so this is the prologue area around
white Orchard this isn't the main open
world it's like a smaller open world
that exists no um if you hold a is the
it basically sticks to the road at uh
the second into three speeds yeah I can
still move roach around this is uh
geralt's horse I can still move around
if I want but he'll uh he'll defaults to
going back on the road to like sticking
to
it and can double tap it and he'll he'll
have not exactly going our way we have a
side the northern Realms we're out of
its Realms don't you mean he's got
stamina at the bottom there's also horse
fear if you wi roach into an area with a
bunch of uh bunch of ghouls or water
hags or drowners or whatever he'll he'll
start to freak out and if if it gets if
he gets too scared he'll basically buck
and you won't be able to uh get out of
there
um we're going to get to white or in a
second that's where we can check out
some of the like I guess the graphical
stuff on the Xbox One just while we're
here though I want to have a little
check at the uh world map and abilities
so where we are right now is uh this
area white Orchard so we can zoom out
to this is the world map this is the
entire game uh the Bima thing and K Mor
are just kind of these tiny little
instanced areas white Orchard uh where
we just were there is this
area which is pretty vable that's where
we are
here kind of zoom out a bit if you zoom
out too much it pops you back to the
world map it's a little it's a little
bit unwieldy when you when you first
started to do it in fact when we first
played this we weren really sure if it
was all connected or not but it's not
this is an instance and then this is the
main area of the game Veil and Norman's
land and this navag area this this is
actually all one big map um and it's
[__]
big that's that's the main city of
novigrad stops up here you can't really
ride much north of there but like this
is the main city of novigrad and we're
going to leave novigrad go down through
some of these like rural regions it's
kind of a marsh land here a bit of a
warfront keep going
down more 10 this is why this game made
me feel like it was Red Dead Redemption
when I was playing it like a fantasy
version keep going down there's all this
marsh land there's all these kind of
mini islands and archipelagos keep going
down uh and it's pretty wide as well it
keeps going wide and so that's only one
of two open worlds which is the crazy
thing the skele ises is a whole other
cett of fish it's a it's a another sort
of uh archipelago of of islands I think
maybe there's five of them all together
there's the main one in the middle
this is a lot more rural a lot less
dense when it comes to
cities and you can fly around on a boat
all around this area as
well uh so you don't get to that for a
little while um like we said the I guess
the sort of main open world
area is where you get to you spend most
of the time after a while it unlocks
this car more and apparently comes up
later on but for the moment we're in
white Orchard which is this little uh
kind of like play pen for the start of
the
game um for fans of the series I kind of
want to highlight this a little bit just
in case people were were looking
wondering about specifics because we got
to report on all this but we had to sort
of pick and choose about what was
important for fans of the series and
newcomers Al like um one thing I'll say
about this in comparison to wiard two
and definitely one is that they've done
a much better job
of like aligning this like RPG
inventories are always pretty messed up
or can be like even have to look at like
something like Skyrim uh the quest area
I love because you will have like
multiple quests on this like for main
quests and side quests and stuff I had
like six running by the time I finished
my my six hours of it um the character
trait stuff is very interesting um the
different leveling progressions I won't
get into it too much here um but it
involves like unlocking secondary
abilities for the signs specking at your
Alchemy uh the mutagens are very
interesting uh this is kind of what this
area over here is as you level up uh so
level two you get this muten slot and
then you can start sticking in these
signs and combat upgrades into these
parts and these are basically like
loadouts that you can swap between in
battle and you unlock the second one at
level 9 and then the third one at 28 I
guess and 16 like and then these are
like you can sort of like swap to them
quickly on the Fly and it's basically
like different loadouts for geralt's
Magical and combat abilities I didn't
get far enough the first time we played
in war so I really play with that but it
looks pretty cool uh the meditation
stuff is here if you want to like get
your Vitality up you want to take some
potions um although you can take potions
just in general play as well um and then
I think there was something over here we
missed I hope I'm covering this all go
for you guys uh you unlock obviously
different crafts uh
different types of uh um weapons and and
wearables uh these all the characters
there's also is fantastic where is it
the Beast I love this the Beast jry is
fantastic every time you come across a
new type of uh uh monster it basically
puts it in here and you can sort of like
it has lists of things that it's
vulnerable against and stuff the Beast
area after about two hours I checked in
there and it was just full of like
really cool um backstory slow Let's uh
let's get back into the story for a
little bit if you just joined the stream
welcome uh this is the winter 3 wild
Hunt running on Xbox One ooh there's
some frame rate Jesus we going
hello it's weird it's like the frame
rate stuff I've noticed so far has been
in like pre-rendered cut scenes and then
this which is in engine but it's not
like it's
all it's not like I'm not controlling
anything as we said this likely doesn't
have the day one patch
so I imagine it will be some frame R
stuff
did I already call it the beastiality or
not I don't
know maybe that's secretly why I like
that menu oh yeah you [__] steal that
horse oh there you
go that Griffin is uh the first Beast
you uh you come up against or Monster
you have to hunt rather has it
gone yeah
come out H do you need to read books uh
for Beast Jerry updates like in The
Witcher 1 and two um I don't think so I
think that stuff gets from what I
noticed pretty detailed information
about
the monsters comes up once you meet them
I think perhaps I don't know but I guess
like some of the details on their
weaknesses and whatnot might come from
that but I don't know when I when I
played it a month ago it felt like that
stuff was pretty when I ran into
a drowner that there was information
about the drowner right there um I ask
this guy for money yeah [__] it I'm a
Witcher could always use a few crowns
thing is I have a Meer purse at the
moment the Meer purse and the worst
haircut mustache combination in the
history of The Witcher which is saying
something
here thanks buddy I just saved your
[__] life don't be so like I said
leads to the main road and ends there
muddle swords upgradable um I don't
actually know I we should ask Kevin
vanard that when he swings
by yes I'm looking for a woman aren't we
all woman medite long black hair seen
anyone like that no but there's an in
here in white Orchard so one around gets
its share of Travelers I know you can
upgrade his armor um you can upgrade
your potions you can upgrade your I
think the bomb as well but I don't
actually know if the upgrades for the
swords are part of his combat ability or
if they're specific to the sword
straight from the cell when I played
previously did you never really got that
far uh all right roach which one roach
you're no sorry sorry roach
faster looks like solid 30 to me right
here so the Griffin this close to the
Village strange one thing I found when I
played this game and looking at it now
is that the worlds are so dense like
there's there's a lived in quality here
that you kind of get in like a Grand
Theft Auto where like it actually feels
like a real city as opposed to every
other open world game it's in a city and
it feels like a video game and we should
leave as soon as we learn anything and
that's the feeling I get here that this
just looks look at this like just people
doing work
and
washing their clothes and stuff all
these people exist on day night cycles
they go to the markets they close up
their stalls they go home at night time
if it rains they run indoors they seek
cover what did the and this is all stuff
I've seen with um with my own eyes
playing
previously does the game ignore the
Witcher 2 endings I haven't played just
heard it had an alternate ending
so there was a part immediately after
this prologue area where you were
basically asked by
a uh a king's servant uh about where you
were During certain kind of like the
start of the Witcher 2 in that there's
like a sort of a backtracking bit it
doesn't you don't play those parts but
you basically fill in probably about six
or seven questions about what happen
the so you get to choose there basically
if you don't care about that stuff you
can op when you start the game for that
question dialogue uh part not to happen
and also Kevin vanard uh at games spot
is sorting out
a sort of a a primer based on those
decisions so people who haven't played
The Witcher 2 can make informed
decisions about what they would have
done if they had played that game so
that'll be up on gam spot in the next uh
next couple of days certainly before the
game is out
if you're wondering where I'm ask
answering the questions it's on the uh
Gamespot chat so if you're watching this
on Twitch or YouTube um get your ass
over to gamespot.com click on the play
wi 3 and uh if you got an account you
can ask questions if you want specific
questions to me as well on that in the
reply tabs you can do Daniel but I'm
actually looking at the uh no need uh
the general chat here as
well Focus jumpy around here armies just
passed through now a Griffin's prowling
about mhm already had the pleasure one
mean beast mean light way for a hunter
to put it oh poor Lena Claude Lena so
bad P things one foot in a grave oh no
but there's no good to wallow in
Misfortune how can I so this area white
Orchard has this main quest which uh you
know holds you by the hand a little bit
to wet your tongue there are certain
things you can do which will uh which
will change up but it's got a bunch of
side quests in here and it also actually
has a second beast quest you can return
to this area once you've uh completed
this little prologue Quest thing as
well uh
okay let's see if I find something
behind the
counter what are you selling what are
you
selling so in
uh in
wonderful form you can RPG form you can
sell and buy I want to buy the weirdest
piece of meat she's got chicken chicken
leg you're going to bite chicken
leg look at that five this is when RPG
stuff comes to L like 21 63 over 5
Seconds how much money I got I'll buy
two chicken legs want to hog all the
legs all right back a woman great violet
eyes dresses in black and white riding
in from will like Beres and uh strange
as it sounds my gooseberries might have
smelled that I forgot about that I've
not seen no smell such a lady believe
I'd remember yeah especially hard to
forget this
one so we don't of all versions people
in the chat wondering uh we haven't got
the PC version yet we had the PC version
that'll probably be the version I'd be
playing right now
um the dialog stuff's really cool as
well like you can you can straight up
finish it it the highlights yellow the
stuff that's like
um importance contract on that Griffin
for the story but there's loads of
optional dialogue like just absolute ton
of optional dialogue there are
characters you'll never meet there are
side quests you'll never run into all
with massive conversations that can
impact on other quests there are
secondary quests which have
conversations that can impact on the
main quests in different ways done not
for free this is seems like an RPG world
that I'm going finish this uh that um
everything really is connected in a way
that most games are like you can't see
the puppet strings the way you kind of
do in a lot of other games H so there's
a couple things around this uh pup that
are interesting sort of evocative of the
the rest of the world we're probably not
going to get into the the the main open
world of this game um in the the two
hours we're streaming today then I'll
ask about yennefer mhm just remember
we'd rather not draw any you can skip
individual lines which is pretty
cool so one of the interesting things
about The Witcher 3 wild Hunt world is
that it seemless in terms of the loading
so if I I can just listen to those guys
having conversation I can go up and have
a chat with
them or I can just I wonder if the game
will let me actually this yeah I can
just go
outside I didn't ask anyone about her uh
oh I hope I can go back in and ask them
later because this is a scripted
fight but there's no loading screens
there's loading screens in
themselves so if I travel to the
skele or if I fast travel within the
open world there be a loading screen
there but if I was just to Potter around
on my own um no loading screens three
against one my oh I can try and use a a
sign to try and get something to back
off haven't done anything to you so just
calm down
ooh of course no I uh you done nothing
horses's working witchcraft horse
son don't call me a horon you're a horse
son Jesus Christ your horon is punching
me so that's cool I've done that before
where
uh where I've actually said three
against one That's mighty Brave and I
fought all three of them let's end
this I'm not really trying to block this
guy at all nice you this guy's just like
yeah
whatever one luck man jobless
she's having a good old
time I'm going to go back in and ask
about
yenifer should save project ear right do
a little do a little manual save
here there's my manual save out
again and now whatever H this guy here
is the gwent dude so if you ever seen
the gwent tutorials that's where that is
uh I don't really want to play went
right now we get the show around this
game on Xbox one I don't want to focus
on freaking card game even though it is
pretty great I'm looking for
someone and we seek some peace and quiet
out in my face freak for your breath
sours my beer yeah people don't like
witches o i
could H I used that before and his
friend freaked out because he saw that I
did us uh did a spell on him this is
will stop the conversation but that be
nice just want to talk just want want to
talk you deaf stray no one here will
talk to you if it's company you seek
stick that mangy snout of yours in a
trough with the pigs these guys are
really unpleasant show that [__] eer
Micha
oh running low on patience once it's
gone your heads will roll yeah we was JY
no call for anger see a raven-haired
woman call me a [__] eater dressed in
black [__] eater we know nothing sir
leave us be
that's a
shame all right don't want to talk to
gwent dude look at this guy sitting on
his own who's got a name gter
odm must be super Irish
name many OD not like everyone and not
just any woman mine smells of lilac and
gooseberries dresses in black and white
two
snapsies it'll lift your
spirits
fine fine I'll have a
drink can we cut to the chase you seen
her or not yennefer of vengerberg
ooh then I guess you
have got a cut on a dress get that sort
of never mentioned her name yet you
described her perfectly and once I hear
something I never forget can't help
it how do you know yennefer What A
Question Master dandelion ballot of
course the only way a humble Merchant
might hope to rub up against greatness
so you tend to pick up little quests
like this just around the world by
getting into chats there's a couple of
side quests involved in this prologue
area as well there's one around the
corner where Rivia himself dwarf's uh
the Butcher of blav like one of his
workshops was burnt down or something
you seen yenifer deepest apologies but a
mustach yeah the guys that said a
project
once I competed this area told me that
there's another beast quest in here as
well none of your business none of your
business yes as a vagrant I deserve no
explanation what do you know tell me I
did not do any voice acting in this game
um I'm not tied to this game in any way
but there are some really cool uh
Regional accents more around the UK and
guardian Scout local Garrison like I
really appreciate it it's really cool
they've got like Co accents Welsh
accents Scottish Irish North England
like real sort of mining town accents
down south people of course of exchange
the Garrison commander and raced off
where
too I'm not omniscient ask at the
Garrison thanks all right so that's
where a lot of this ends up going is
that there's
a Garrison in this area oh this guy's
still hanging out should I beat him up
can I beat him up no jump on
him yeah that'll serve you H let's have
a little wander around this
area hey
peasant up some
mushrooms what do you
want so I you can go into some of these
houses I'm not sure if we can go into
this
one
okay this hey what's up what's going
on it's
Pleasant that guy looks
wasted this is very interesting actually
i' I've noticed a couple of things
around this whole area that happened in
quests I did later in this area that
have actually are
accurate even though I haven't triggered
the quest so that's that's actually
pretty incredible I don't want to tell
you though just in terms of uh spoilers
H let's check out some of this this is
running on Xbox one we're streaming this
in 720 for those who are wondering
um God Kings do the
fighting but peasants do the dying any
Tidings from
Vima some of these aren't real
conversations look at this just the
detail and some of like
the another thing that's new in the
series is uh geralt can now
swim so you can go
underwater a little bit gets a little
bit used to you have to get a little bit
used to it it's kind
of you push
forward and B is go up X's go
down and then if you're on the surface
you can basically swim a little faster
uh that's cool i' there are Subterranean
there are like caves that you can access
uh especially in the skela parts of the
world um there's a there's a treasure
pile that I found around this part of
the world actually at one stage it was
protected by some drowners that I had to
dispatch so there's a lot to uh lot to
discover we've done a lot of story stuff
so I kind of want to spend the next like
5 10 minutes just wandering around so if
you guys uh got in the chat have any
suggestions um by all means put them in
I'll see if I can accommodate them
you're strange but a good fell Noel
thank
you oh what I want to show you is the
notice board so each town has a
signpost which is used as a fast travel
location um not sure if the prologue
area actually subscribes to that or if
it's just in the open world par and
they've also got um
what got notice boards which have quests
on them one thing I'm noticing which I
really liked in the PC version and I'm
I'm seeing a lot on the Xbox One first
of all Shadows are fantastic uh but the
see just like the Ambi Ambience like
dust that gets kicked off you see that a
lot in this game and like even here you
can see it where it's kind of like
pollen and dust kicked up from the road
uh it looks really
good would be an RPG unless you had an
inventory full of
hundreds of random plants you don't know
what to do with
um just the way the houses are built
into the world it's just unlike so many
other
games uh that guy over there is a side
quest the dwarf what the [__] am I to do
um I don't I kind of want to do that
side okay we might do that side quest
cuz maybe that's off the story so we
might do that instead cuz it's pretty
I love this this kid is singing in
nursery rhyme and once I pass by his
yeah his dad doesn't like him saying
that so these notice boards are
absolutely brilliant so each 10 has one
of these and some of them are quests
like this one here Bast then my brother
went off to fight the black ones I
reason to think he stood in a great
battle nearby so I can picked I can
straight up pick that off the board and
that's like a new quest for me to
do uh but then the rest of them were
just random notic this and some of them
are [__] so dumb like what's this one
don't understand what it just read no
wonder it's a n guardian and soon half
the world will be speaking this
mysterious tongue so you'd best start
learning it now and yours truly can help
you with that for a modest Fe this guy's
going to teach people how to speak nil
Guardian um so the nil guard have are
basically an army who have built an
outpost close to this town uh so some of
this stuff like points you in the
direction of quest I saw one here that
was some guy who basically said hey
don't eat cats it was like the top of it
like you shouldn't need cats I ate a cat
once and I had bad luck for a week so I
just want everyone else in the village
to know that you shouldn't need cats uh
and there's just loads of that like dark
humor humor peppered around this uh this
world you know what I don't think the
side quest has been shown
before it's only one of area in this
little prologue area let's let's get it
It Up and
Smoke what happened
here oh got a we bit chilly the night so
I set fire to my Forge nice and roaring
roasted some wieners what do you think
happened dwit some bugger allar are
Scottish I've lost everything
everything don't insult me easy on the
insults I could add to your misfor
Fortune any suspects whole damned
Village I've lived here half a century
thought they saw me as one of their
own take off pants that's a good sh
actually I might see if I can do the
rest of this Quest nak I got
to bang plate shoe horses I'm going to
skip a little bit of this chat Guardians
don't pay me a bloody copper so this
guy people in the village are unhappy
with him because he's basically fixing
weapons for the nil guard even though
they don't pay him uh I'm gonna find
your arsonist there somebody in the town
burn down his Forge not much left but
I'll give you but uh there's a contract
out here so I wouldn't be a Witcher if I
didn't pick up random uh quests from
some people uh let me see if I can strip
uh strip geralt down to
his his pink skin where are we
at
equipment
ibles oh it's over here isn't it
trousers
unequip boots
unequip chest armor
unequip I leave the gloves on the gloves
kind of make them look more naked yeah
there you go all right now we're ready
to witch let's do
it I know for a fact that this
particular Quest Actually I don't even
know for a fact I don't think this
particular Quest requires combat so I
don't feel too bad about stripping them
down um what's this I can loot I don't
want to steal the guy's stuff thought he
was going to help me oh I can uh I can
uh kind of enhance my weapons over here
so you can upgrade your weapon here I
guess enhance oh that actually just gave
me a buff see the timer underneath the
Vitality stuff on the top left so you
get those a lot if you uh come across
for instance um there are like uh points
uh like little what would you call you
call them like shavings from a Tinder
Box little Sacred Stones that give you
little toed on the Roof then fled
through the or for a while bootprints a
man's large I find this is a these are
some Footprints leading away from his
lodge I'm in Witcher I'm basically in
detective mode Witcher mode
here uh I'm going to keep following
these find some more clues stinks of
piss and
vodka his and vodka that's a good
Saturday night for
me all right where we
going keep falling don't go in the water
don't go in the
water where we at took off his boot
boots and went in the water probably
wanted to cover his Trail so let's uh go
for the swimmy over here
maybe yeah it's nice to feel
that feel that water on your naked ass
isn't it
geralt oh here we
go something jumped out of the rushes
drowners but he managed to escape oh
there's drers
here the drers are
like like zombie people who drowned
they're oh man he was naked look at this
dude with a out a sword once too did he
kill that duck with your crossbow kid so
I think this is one of the markets that
like gets closed up later in the day can
I kill this duck I remember when I kill
you kill a chicken and Skyrim and
suddenly the entire town wants to murder
you I'm kind of scared of uh beding not
badly he's bleeding surface
wound so earlier when I went into this
house that's what I was sort of alluding
to was Happ your
mug trail ends here hey hey lady don't
worry about me I'm just coming
in no uh drowner CL on it's got to be
him what happened to
you nasty wound run into a drowner what
the [__] do you care whoa wow our
arsonist a charmer too come on Smith
wants to talk to you I not talk to are
nonhuman sons of [__] all and dwarves
are the worst greedy little Magpie do
anything for gold they will they Forge
the blades the black ones put to our
throat am I not right if you're reading
this faster than they saying it you can
skip as well which is pretty cool we can
work this out manto man I give you gold
o you don't turn me in my mom died a
while back and I sold her tools I've
spent some but what what's left is yours
oh this is a
dilemma okay so he can pay
me or I can bring him back to the
dwarf okay so I've brought him back
before I'm going to pay I'm going to
take his money this time because I'll
tell you what happens when he choose the
other one uh fine no more arson just
give me some cash I'll I'll turn you to
cheek fine I'll look agree to that if
you swear to stop playing with
fire fail to do that and I'll come back
and someone will get hurt of course
Master Witcher I swear on me dead mom
your gold and here's to your health down
with the black ones and nonhumans alike
no no no I'm not saying it's okay that
you're racist that's not I know you're
giving me the money but I'm not saying
[__] off already all
right okay got some XP and a bit of cash
hopefully when I come back to this town
later it hasn't like completely burnt
down because of this guy uh I guess I'll
have to wait and see that's a sort of
stuff that does happen in The Witcher um
okay now to tell you what happens if you
choose the other way if you choose the
other way you can basically cast igny or
Not igny Jesus Christ um You cast
h axie on that guy and bring him back to
the dwarf and when I did that the dwarf
had him hung by the N guards so the N
guard were passing by and he basically
said yo hang this guy just for burning
down his uh his little uh little Forge
and obviously for being a massive racist
which is which is probably worse um yeah
but he had him killed and I remember
thinking oh I wouldn't have brought him
back here if you if I knew you were
going to murder him so I wonder how this
is going to
go couldn't track your arsonist down
sorry about that DN shame
well the black ones might catch him
eventually am ice do you need anything I
managed to save some things from the
fire and my Anvil's whole buy something
else all right a return customer welcome
look can
to uh craft something i' like you to
forge something for
me ooh so I don't have components for
this uh piece of armor so this is where
the sort of the the crafting stuff gets
nice and deep so this is when you're
picking up different items purchasing um
different components from vendors and
whatnot and there's a lot to do here
um let's not get into it right
now we only got another hour or so left
of this bye-bye sorry about your whole
arson problem uh sorry I did this entire
Quest naked as well I should probably
sort that
out
great that's going like okie dokie so
let's have a look at our Quest so if you
can see on the right side um lilac and
gooseb that's our main quest we have
there sorry the right side underneath
the map you can see that it's it's
sitting over there um I also picked up
that other Quest
though secondy Quest here which uh was
from the notice board so I can click on
that bad boy as
well and then that changes the the we
point on the
map um points me in a different
direction um I'm not sure if I need a
couple more quests or maybe I need to
get out of the this area to to open that
stuff up but I remember there being a
situation where I had a bunch of uh
quests almost kind of World of Warcraft
Style on the right side of the screen
underneath that map now listen carefully
which is pretty cool you never to see
again all right so I need roach so if I
click in on the left stick twice geralt
whistles a little our boy turns up I see
you with him again let's get off to This
n
Guardian base I
guess uh can you attack NPCs in the
village you know what I don't actually
know let me see about
that
um all right here let
me oh okay here's the the main menu let
me save
got
sa I don't want to do it when there's n
guard actually around I don't
necessarily want to do it in the village
oh whatever [__] it we can always reload
it let's just make sure that this has
actually saved cuz this would be a real
bummer if just murdered everyone and
then it like oh no game's over
man you think I can attack the boy
if I take my sword out do people react
differently do not get food not for me
oh I'm not looking for
food I Target you
guys I can't Target them
anyway
uh interesting if I swipe
she freaks out but if I try and hit him
he just lifts up his fist and then
doesn't do anything so how about the N
card sheath your weapon
oh I guess
not although maybe children are exempt
from this
rule nope but I can scare the [__] out
of him so that's fun all
right let's get on before the Run roach
yeah run get out of here I just
threatened the child with murder
oh man this game is so
pretty a Gallop so this open world this
little of miniature prologue open world
in white Orchard is uh not particularly
big but
it it's not a it's
uh it's it it's when you get into the
main open world you sort of realize the
the type of scale that move it that The
Witcher 3 is is running at
the fact you can sort of like navag when
you I think when you first go to navag
grad and you find that big city that's
pretty astounding as well it sort of
reminds you about how
the Oh there wolves I bet how the
the loading stuff works as well uh we're
fighting wolves here I'm actually going
to Prime this bad boy cuz I think that
these guys are all standing around a
bunch of
that like crates of Dynamite or fuel or
something looks like that is over
there come on
wol here we
go
time didn't
work
it is one of these situations where
maybe using something like herden as a a
good
shout oh poison has get out of
there these guys want slow down
now block you you
jerk level five
wolf
what else we got I'm going to try and
detonate him on
that again this is on the second of four
difficulties
so there we
go
boom yeah your buddy over there didn't
survive h i can loose Fallen uh foes I
think this is actually lootable here as
well
yeah got some scraps
oh here we go I'll take all that
please oh I think this is just one of
those games there is a full uh day night
cycle as well which we we may end up
dumping into
but I got it the first time I played
this I'm I'm I'm feeling it again where
you know that feeling where you just
know you're going to be hanging out here
you're just going to be one wandering
around this world for like the next 3
weeks it's uh it's something
special all right
roach we're almost at the nil Guardian
base they've set up in this uh this this
abandoned
castle at their little Outpost so we're
going to go in there we're going to ask
about
yennefer see if uh see if those folks
know know what's
up
move it yeah that's right sit-ups keep
going slow all right this doesn't seem
very horse friendly I'm going to leave
you here
roach uh like I said actually just in
case you didn't know The Witcher is uh
he's got those two swords on his back uh
hitting the Lefty pad brings out the
silver one uh sorry the right one left
de brings out the the steel I guess um
which is used mostly for humans or U
non-magic beasts I guess yes uh so I'm
going to go up here oh there's a this is
I think this is one of the Fast Travel
points stop this might be the first one
you run into actually so these are the
the uh notice boards which where the
Fast Travel works
from you can basically travel to any
other fast travel location you have uh
the prolog area isn't the best example
of of jumping between these
but that's the Garrison there and then
white Orchard is is down here so I can I
can go down to the bridge there like I
said it's not the biggest area it's it's
a this veil in novograd part is the
where most of the madness
happens uh
okay go up
here talk to these fine gentlemen
military Camp no locals allowed without
the ex I don't know about incum uh they
haven't picked up enough items look like
a local to you yeah we might get Kevin
in here later on to ask a couple of
those specific questions that and
upgrading swords was another one that
was
asked Captain Peter swin leevy is in the
tower turn right pass the gate oh
everyone thinks this is the castle in
the first
game that' be cool you can be nice huh
you black ones aren't so scary after all
can even be nice if you want to don't
get accustomed nordling to the tower
go again you just wander into this
little
village Outpost there's a lot of stuff
going on here you can go up and talk to
the mil Guardians most of them are just
kind of like witch or two style they
just give you a little
line never know there you always get the
feeling that there could be some side
quest anywhere you go which is almost as
good as their being side quests
everywhere you
go talked to the Quarter Master about
getting supplies but just for the sake
of brevity I'm going to head in here how
much grain will your village give
whatever you say your
Excellency look at my hands look see the
calluses these are not the hands of an
Excellency but of a farmer so we speak
peasant to Peasant how much can you give
40 bushels there' be more so but our
Lads the tamarians that is took from us
earlier and you will give 30 and that
will do let us settle on it and I wish
to see the transport soon nice oh thank
you sir thank you kindly what a solid
dude I summoned only the elderman and
the Smith Willis is this game mod
friendly like Skyrim uh you are too to
seems like they're
maybe trying to get into that area at
some stage but right at the gate there
is no mod tool I don't know if it's mod
friendly in terms of people breaking it
open themselves um we're previously
talking to CD project this SED like
something they wanted to do but right
now on launch it doesn't seem like
they're they're going in that direction
hopefully hopefully soon they'll talk
about that stuff
um very perceptive of you he's a nice
dude geralt of Rivia Witcher
V this explains why I did not hear your
footsteps what do you see here yennefer
of vengerberg where was she headed SK is
a military secret oh [__] haven't
thrown me out yet haven't called to go
what's your price there is a griffin oh
really it's a deal it's a
deal it kept vulpine Woods at first I
sent Pine Woods I wonder if there's
wolves in there young man a hunter found
them 2 days
on since then the Griffin has has grown
b i we ran into the griin it's abandoned
its Lair going to have to set a trap I
judge from your tone this is what I
really love about The Witcher um games
and the the sort of lore and and very
much wild Hunt as well I'll need bait a
specific herb is it like he's the like
he's he's thinking about okay left the
nest I need to get this Buckthorn stuff
to I do not lure the Griffin out I'll
have to use like a certain type of
potion or I'll have to a certain typ of
weapon take it down and all this stuff
is kind of like it's handed to you on a
PL in this prolog area they let you you
know there's so many variables that
exist in this open world to fighting the
beasts like there are specific monsters
that you really only want to fight
during nighttime there are certain ones
that like in specific terrains are much
more dangerous um need more information
I'm going to ask him about more
information about the Griffin abandoned
its layer shall I bring you Witnesses
they won't say anything I don't already
know I need to go where your men died
look around
mof he has I'm going to go down to where
the last attack was and try and get more
uh more
information that's cool it's like a
reminds you of like God I don't want to
I was about to make an LA Noir uh
reference but maybe like just gathering
information setting it all up like
queuing up all the information for like
for the battle for the the moment where
you finally meet up and what's cool
about wild Hunt is that you can kind of
do this oh nice slide you can kind of do
this stuff alongside sliding downstairs
confirmed and alongside doing all your
secondary quests and your main quests
and all that stuff
um so it feels real natural you're like
kind of investigating and then going off
and doing a side quest or getting lost
and then coming back
and this prologue area is is much more
leading you by the hand but certainly in
terms of the the open worldall part of
the game later
on got of take it at your own pace kind
of feels like is real good actually I'm
going to I'm going to stick to the coast
here there's a bridge up here which last
time oh all right roach let's
go yeah like I said if you just joined
if he just tapped
twice he'll just Gallop down the road
slow now whoa all right there's it
there's there's some stuff going on so
these are drowners I'll give you the
back story of these guys in a second
once I ice this
guy where we got where we got what we
got oh yeah it doesn't stop time ring as
well by the way when that happens Jesus
Christ
oh
oh you think think I'm going to make
it
damn so Vitality looks like I'm going to
have to eat my uh my chicken wings H so
the game is way better than the Witcher
one and Witcher 2 at teaching you how to
play it like Witcher 2 was before they
patched it was just almost impenetrable
so even then this isn't part of a
tutorial but they're like yo you can eat
equipment as you play to consume items
in the first lot press up and the second
aot press down so at the moment my
consumables are chicken oh sorry this
bread
situation and what's underneath it
water so I'm going to swap out the bread
some hot chicken
leg put it in there and
then I can press
up have some chicken leg is down for
water all all that cool Downs pop up
there as this is also how the potions
work you kind of make the potions you
discover the potions first time and then
you kind of deploy them whenever you
want and and then when you instead of
having to make them from the specific
ingredients every time like in The
Witcher 2 there a base level of alcohol
uh and every time you meditate it
basically pulls it off that H so what I
love about the detail here is that like
there's the drowners is there there's a
dead dude there there's like clearly
been some sort of scuffle on this bridge
there's a SW that's
missing there's a [__] Dragon K my
ass
Jesus I'm trying to cast BS
here Jesus Christ kind of blocking it
but not really there you
go have some more water chicken
legs drer brain it's a master craft item
yeah see this there kind of like all
this stuff here and and you might think
anything of it but also you could hop
down
here and straight up the there's a
carriage that that came off whenever
that whenever that little battle
happened W you know
it some loot military orders
florens and what do you know a quest and
this was something that I discovered the
first time I played this game a month
ago um in in Poland and that kind of
sums up what the w why The Witcher 3 is
so exciting to me is that you were just
walking around minding your own business
they put the car and attention into like
creating this little area with really
like a hidden Quest like there was no
reason to jump underneath that bridge
unless you like took the time and
attention to see that like this guy
crawled out of the water and I wonder
what happened here the first time I
passed I came from the other side and
actually it seemed a bit more noticeable
that's why I went underneath the
water and I got myself a
quest if that doesn't make you hype to
bed The Witcher then uh I don't know
will and this is another really
interesting thing about this game is the
treasure hunt level four secondary
quests suggested level three here so
geralt keeps leveling up as you play the
game the side quests don't they stay the
same so you will pick up levels that are
like level 30 that you won't be able to
do for 100 hours or uh Kevin said that
one of the bad parts actually was that
he there was so many interesting little
uh missions he kept bumping into but
then they were like they were actually
10 levels below where he was so there's
even I feel like there's a desire to
want to uh maybe play through the game
on
different different playthroughs uh
there all your information here and the
tutorial stuff which is really cool if
you're stuck at any moment you can hop
back in here and then the beaster is
getting a little bit filled up since
we've playing this game for a while so
we got
beasts we got
hybrids there
Griffin uh and we have all the
information which is interesting
drowners drowner resembles a corpse
dredge from the bottom of a pond it's
sickly blue or green in color with slime
and sludge oozing into of every place
the acate stench of rash wafting off of
it then it's got like a little bit of
information there but igny you know fire
beats water What potions you should use
I should probably look into that and
like and just like a like a little bit
of lore like when at the water's edge
you got to be quiet first of all so it's
not to scare the fish second so you
don't attract drers like just little
bits of lore I wonder if they're
actually pulled from from the
books like the world of The Witcher is
is one of very
few fleshed out pieces of of lore and it
and perhaps it like I think it benefits
greatly from the fact that it exists in
literature and it's not just all created
by artists and and and writers in the in
the sort of the the moments they have
between making the game like this is it
Andre shapi or sapowsky his name is like
he created this world and this rule set
and that's kind of there for set a
project to to fill in the gaps as it
were so I think that lends itself to a
much more interesting type of world in
the same way that like Skyrim is much
more interesting in terms of it's lower
than say you
know any of the ear like the earlier
Elder sculls games because if they've
had time to sort of to fill themselves
out and to create a a universe that's
believable and and has a cannon that's
worth respecting and I think that's the
same thing that kind of you get with The
Witcher but right off the bat because it
already has like a bunch of
books uh all right let's hop in here
anyone
home must be out
hunting all right if you said hunting
I'll use
my my Batman Vision Trails fresh find
where he is just left home all right ml
where you
at I don't even need to use that I can
just see his
footprint NOP I take it
back uh and another wonderful thing
about the quest that I've experienced so
far is that the there he is
is that use of different systems all the
time like got little horse rid we kind
of got that drowner thing happened on
the way but we might we got a little bit
of a little bit of using The Witcher
sense now we're going to have a little
bit of conversation we're going to go on
a hunt wolves no well dogs good variety
of the yes types of systems that you're
using in anyone
Quest where'd you find the bodies body
pots I'm hunting bigger game the N
Guardians the Griffin killed where'd you
find them ah I see you a Witcher that
monster Slayer they's talking about in
the
village I'll show you sure but uh I got
to kill those muts for no worries will
you help that is if you don't mind
blunting your silver blades on
them that's a nice little reminder of uh
sure G Sil any no dogs might though
these dogs beening for a while now since
the war
started that's
steal woman Strangler killer look how
[__] beautiful look at this Jesus
Christ kicking passing no
more the Xbox One version looks even
better on PC but look at this Jes like
just remind yourself of other open world
games on the Xbox One for a moment just
think about Watch Dogs and then a look
have a look at
this this is really something
else just even the like the
the like the technical aspect of it sure
but just even like the the Artistry of
this like it just feels like it feels
cold now that I'm in the shade you can
like really see that light piercing
through the moisture in the air in the
distance that kind of fog I think when
the wind stuff kicks up it's incredibly
impressive uh so there's a bunch of
different wind systems in this game that
determine the trees movements down to
like geralt's hair and like the hair on
beasts and whatnot so the first time I
went to to that nil Guardian Base today
when we went to The Outpost it was like
nice and sunny and relatively calm when
I went there uh when I played this game
previously it was during like a wind
storm and during all those conversation
cut piece part uh cut scene Parts
um geralt's hair was like blowing all
over the place like a crazy
person it's like going to let him kill
that
stuff I have some bread actually eat
some
bread you know what I'm going to help
him
man don't hit me with
your [__] come on focus on that
one I wonder if that's why the drers
were were not dying fast although I
wasn't getting out of way either but
Jesus hit me with
that I need to get better at my block
queing up that left trigger block is
proving difficult for
me what we
got yeah that's right I set your corpses
on fire apologies I kept hitting uh I
kept hitting right button instead of uh
right trigger I was trying to cast
igny what we got
here ask the herous about books on come
on have a
chat
Deeter you know him we served the Lord's
M crossbow doesn't come up until later
you actually get it right as you fight
the Griffin for the first time was the
Lord's Hunter um so there's no crossbow
quite
yet well a long time
ago sorry hope you weren't close no not
at all so can you show me where you
found enough
Guardians Griffin know anything about it
not much it's not my kind of CH oh he
love leveled up let's have a look at the
character trait stuff actually this will
be an interesting little side thing to
do um while we're
here so the character leveling H we
haven't got any mutagens yet or maybe we
do uh you receive ability points every
time you gain a level using these points
you can acquire new abilities improve
the ones you have it's pretty much power
for the course uh this is the ability
stuff um the colors red is for combat uh
blue is for uh Magic I believe and then
green is for Alchemy
um then you can level them up here
choose which one you
want fast
attack strong
attack this is defense stuff
Marksmanship battle
trance so muscle memory fast attack
increased by 5% at General points game
so it's
pretty granular as it happens
uh I can put it into the uh the sign
stuff here and upgrade my art or my igny
or whatever I can put it into Alchemy un
upgrade how my potions work when I use
them or effectiveness of my grenades and
whatnot um and then these
are General sort of traits you can
upgrade as well Griffin School technique
each piece of medor armor increases sign
intensity of 5% we're getting into real
RPG mechanics here um I'm going to go
with ooh 50% slower when using a
crossbow that's something I definitely
would have gone for in Skyrim for
instance
uh let's go with yeah 5% extra damage on
a that's pretty pretty easy one let's do
that yeah why not so this is the
interesting little ability area so for
an ability to take effect you must
activate it and put it in a slot
inactive abilities won't have any effect
you can unlock abilities and then not
use them and so this almost works like
your inventory you basically pick up one
of these guys put it in a
slot and it's part of one of your
ability
loadouts you can deactivate abilities at
anytime and activate other ones whenever
you want so this is these loadouts
aren't set in stone you can mess with
them whenever you want and the other
thing which we won't get to yet is that
when you get the mutagens that's where
these guys go and they they're kind of
more powerful effects and you can go
between these different loadouts of
effects uh as you go we won't get that
fourth uh uh our third unlock slot until
level four instincts alone ought to make
you care I walk silent through the woods
no Griffin PR in this game even ones
like this La here you kind of bump into
they always feel like they're pretty
fleshed out just walking through leaves
here to give them
that if I run faster he'll run faster as
well
on a nice day in white Orchard
greetings you have your horse come to
you double press
L sure can but why would I do that when
I
can follow the hunter it has me on the
other Quest I'm not sure how I can fix
that how do I fix
that for some reason the map is thinking
I'm on the second part of this
Quest oh it wanted me to do the
herbalist first did
it sorry game I'm a
mislav show me where the N guards are oh
here they are Jesus
Christ it was here sure was one lay
there by the stump
headless watch out for
yourself I'll be
fine I'll beine fine not the first
Griffin I've dealt with hope you're
right good hunting now see you there
dude all right so I'm going to use
my super detective
skills my Witcher vision black saturated
with blood have a little look
around NE Guardians were
celebrating Griffin interrupted
them it looks like this was an actual
Outpost there there animals in the
distance you can use that if you're
hunting and
whatnot sounds like wolves we are in the
vulpine forest after
all take my sword out just in
case uh what are what are I can a
camp can I set that fire no I
can't any other
uh Blues around this part of
town I'm more worried about those guys
oh here we
go these prints are older and deeper
heavily
armored Guardians probably all right
let's follow
them o loot Hello whoa sweet [__]
vert pipe
man get some linen I'm worried about
those uh those wolves coming over
here Jesus
why can't I walk up the side of
everything like in Skyrim let's go this
way all right where those tracks at here
we
go
so hop on up here I'm definitely getting
more used to the the
controller controls on this
pad at the start at walking around and
doing this sort of stuff was a little
bit hot Hazard but seems a bit more
normal
now did I pass those where' they
go go up
here it goes up
here jump
across yeah Griffin's nest what remains
of it at least there's a dead dude
corpse is a couple of weeks home
still alive when the Griffin brought him
here oh man that's a dead Griffin right
there female larv and her wounds have
already hatched been dead at least a
week other Griffin must be a
male de over the whole body not a drop
of blood on the beak or claws didn't
defend herself crept up on her while she
slept just that type of like depth
really beak tips War adds so much to
Quest that other games could have just
been yo go kill that freaking Griffin
pair off for life when young male must
be about the same age so they basically
just killed his wife thick shaft dense
barbs Royal
Griffin explains why the male I ran into
was so aggressive hunted the nil
Guardians down here in the forest first
then started prowling the
area
Man Poor
dude love it's telling me to prepare for
combat o actually look at this guy I'll
take your Veil and long
sword huh so I guess that answers the
questions about the
swords where are we
at here got a veil and long sword we
just got three plus three damage and
what about this thing armor repair kit
sure why
not um if I'm right from the last time I
played this over here see that little
question mark on the map in the top uh
place of power it's got to be so the
controller just rumbled and if you can
see I'm not sure if you
can uh geralt's Medallion around his
neck that vibrates whenever there's
magic so that's uh let me know that this
guy's
here uh oh it's giving me an ability
point and it's also I think upgraded my
Gwen for the next 30
minutes pretty
cool thanks magical thing in the woods
uh so the next thing I have to
do is head over to the
herbalist
get me some
bud over in this little
town and that's already on the on the
marker so let's get roach again he can
turn up basic oh you're behind me the
whole time roach oh I didn't
know come on
roach am I going to have to jump over
this bridge how do I jump on the horse x
b let's go through the
woods no Road can hold
me H there is this straight up Combat on
the horse as well you can cut people
down just ride straight through Fields
sorry
guys actually I want to go this way
don't I oh no I want to go this way got
approach think she's over
here oh sorry
dude whatever you stay
there about
thealist what's going
on bad time not at all hand me the
beggar tickets the red Bloom well well
one vers in herbs probably saying too
much but I know a bit for instance that
beggar ticks poisonous in large doses
small ones soothe pain and bring forth
pleasant dreams o nice which is all I
can hope to do for her this is the lady
got attacked by the Griffin I think on
the bed Buckthorn please for Buckthorn
know if it grows anywhere around here h
bottom of the river where the channels
wide it'll stink worse than I'm hunting
I was
thinking Captain Peters I'm going to I'm
going to book it through this because I
want to actually get to the Griffin
flight within our 2hour time window here
true and you're in a hurry I am in a
hurry do you know I'm skipping through
dialog options right now next
time
uh a lot of these people I imagine you
return to later in the game as well or
maybe not feel like that the game could
go either way so now I need to get this
Buckthorn stuff which is basically the
stinkiest weed in the world H it's down
by the you you're feel you're free to
hunt these animals by the way as well
and actually use their meat um if you
want uh but it's a it's a a pretty
stenchy weed that the Griffin the Royal
Griffin in particular
um is attracted
to did he just get freaked out because
there drers here
you just stopped a second ago I wonder
why run roach yeah I think there's a
drer underneath the water
there where we were
earlier um am I on the right side of the
river oh right I forgot about this got
to go for a
swimmy using one of geralt's new
abilities okay just look at this goddamn
video
game
at
that
Jesus oh man this is something else all
right I'm going to go down here and get
some some nasty
weed get some Primo
Kush all is it swimming controls are a
little bit panicky but oh [__] there's a
bunch of stuff down here
and my breath of course is at the
top and I've got
my got my
weed so let's head over
to White Orchard again should talk to
vamir make sure vamir is clued in he's
hanging out at the bar just in case you
forgot we kind of left him there a while
ago probably three sheets to the win
right
now but it's a nice day so why not uh we
let Roach hang out over there and let's
just go for a
walk and this game is
pretty
jeez so as the day kind of lingers on
all these people start to go home turns
to night time and
they'll hello dog vied Hill Riser and
they'll go home je look at
that
oh I'm a sucker for a good video
game Sunset and that is something
else all right sorry get back to the oh
there's a storm coming in
Jesus look at
this let's get the vzm here before
this yeah rain is rain in important jeez
look how dark it is over here storm
clouds are just rolling
in all great looking for trouble good
manir is that the other river by the
wood yes what is it
wolf got good news and bad news good
news first captain of a guardian
Garrison knows where you and the bands
that we have to kill the Griffin yeah
nailed it what else could he want from
two Griffin's abandoned its lir and
how's that
going I got the buck Thorn got the buck
more like stench city boy remember I
also got the information so I guess I
could have come back the N Guardians
burn and I talked to him earlier and he
would have given me advice but uh let's
just do it let's kill griin out of good
so this is the culmination of the
prologue area um this uh map that we're
about to do now so we're going to
prepare for the Griffin fight by Brewing
some Thunderbolt so let's go into the
Alchemy this is part of
the one of the main sort of ort of
pillars of this world is that you create
these potions that then you you take
before battle so I'm going to go find
thunderbolt where is
it green M red
muten cash
Jesus and then I'm going to craft
it
so now I can go to the
inventory go over to the potion
menu I'm going to uh choose this bad boy
and then put it in one of the slots in
the consumable one at the
bottom and that's the way in which this
game is a little bit different
to the other games is that you have to
always do your meditation whereas in
this I can just hit down and take my
Thunderbolt I probably shouldn't have
taken that cuz it's only lasts for 30
seconds but whatever yeah I can hear
claps in the background sorry
guys this is cool the last time I fought
this Griffin um let's get on our horses
actually roach where you at where you at
though he always comes from the side
you're not
looking um move it the first time I did
this it was a beautiful sunny day uh and
there was a storm earlier in the day I
think the the I think the daylight
Cycles about I think it's an hour and a
half or two hours or something might be
somewhere in there um whereas this time
it's it's happening it's happening
during this uh this storm which I guess
it kind of almost looks like they set it
up on purpose but I swear to God the
first time I played this it was it was a
pretty
day and I'm a little bit I've already
done this before but I'm actually a
little bit nervous about amber waves of
grain Charming Place perfect for an
ambush I know how to choose them so
ready we can start let's start winds me
bait sent will spread quick
quickly F fake ass no I just had this
fake sheep with me the whole time we can
cower in the shade of those
Birches so tell you can sleep it does
change the got your eye on a contract no
I'll go to Cam little early to settle in
for the winter snows are a way off yes
and that's what worries me so after this
part after this battle you guys
parts for a while and well I assume is a
while I'm sure he comes back later in
Valley cover the you're on your own with
h geralt speaking of winter and
wintering think you'll come this year
maybe might bring a
guest just love this little conversation
as they wait for the the Griffin to
arrive yeah I've still got two more uh
two more
little shots of Thunderbolt
left let going to keep it a warm welcome
I love this watch it here we go take
this you the master of
crossbows a crossbow wanted in a card
game while you run around might come in
handy play some
gwent took you for a tradition list
witchers don't actually use wange
repping so this is a a Witcher with a
crossbow we breaking with tradition stop
talking got a griffin to kill he doesn't
care I love that they address
it okay wish me luck this is the first
monster battle of the game it's in the
prologue area the rest of it's all part
of the open world
so here we
are I like the
crossbow it's about to
die
[__]
earlier than that
maybe yeah eat
it yeah come
on where am I at what I got it's me come
on
get behind
him
[__] all right let's take some
Thunderbolt I'm going to have some bread
quick a [__] don't go in the air the
minute I take my Thunderbolt you
[__] come
on
God damn
it damn it's fast [__] is fast my
health is not doing too
good come
on can use the crossbow in this
situation as well uh just doesn't take
off that much it's usually just for
taking them
down my Thunderbolts worn off again
which is a big a
paint [__]
next come
on she G
down miss
me
[__]
oh man all
right
[__] yeah roach you want to get out of
the way
mate I almost feel like I just want to
like take little pop shots at him just
to take that energy down got him at
about half but my might Health sucks no
I don't want to get on
roach Dodge Dodge
oh you
suck man all
right hey man it wouldn't be a Witcher
game unless you couldn't kill your first
boss the first time
around oh uh I played this on the
easiest difficulty um for a little while
as well and uh not this time around
obviously but uh and that that this
stuff could be a lot easier but
the combat in this game learning how to
do it in that same sort of dark
soulsyoutube
honest I'm kind of thinking maybe I
might stick to the second of four uh
but uh I'm interested so we we sa I
saved about an hour ago so I haven't
saved since then so I'm wondering how
good the uh it said it Autos saved after
every sort
of little story bit this is the first
loading screen we've come up against um
since we
started I think and it's pretty long but
uh also remember this isn't the super F
this isn't the final
code uh or well rather it is this is
retail but we we think that maybe the
day one patch isn't on this I can't say
either
way
uh just just as well you can tell
there's not many loading screens in this
game because the haven't really done
much the Jazz this one
up so if you want to come back in like
an hour maybe
we'll get back to the
fight still
loading this game is pretty good uh
we're actually going be ring up pretty
soon maybe we'll just ran it up there
ran it up there we want to go for a
little while it kill it all right kill
what kill it kill the stream or kill the
Griffin gin okay all right we got to
kill the Griffin what's this game loads
uh if you're just joining us or if you
don't you haven't been here since the
start and we're playing on the Xbox One
version of The Witcher 3 wild Hunt which
of course is out on Xbox One PC and
Playstation 4 next Tuesday you can uh
you can pre-load it and pre
purchase it now to your uh to your
content on I think every platform now
PS4 Xbox
One um the PC one via Steam and also
gog.com GG uh which is CD projects or
sedep project um own game purchasing
Service uh if you want a DRM free
version of that as is uh as is the way
it goes this loading screen is no
[__] joke I'm almost thinking this is
like
we're in we're in Crash territory here
let's try and jump back and jump back
in yeah all right let's do this thing I
think it crushed oh
wait yeah I think it
crashed um there were some technical
hiccups on uh Kevin's side he said with
some quests apparently that stuff's
getting patched out in not even in day
one patch and the second patch they're
going to be rolling out um uh Jeff G
went over joh bomb said he had a couple
of uh um crashes when he did the gwent
tutorial uh we just played for two hours
um uninterrupted and apart from that um
uh loading bug we didn't see anything
else um I I kind of want to see where
this ends up dropping us back in just
for the sake of hopefully it's right
before the Griffin fight we can get
stuck back
in
um but I'm also just sort of generally
interested as well
yep I
know I see you
got
continue this part's taale begins near
White Orchard so they give you a little
bit of every time you load back in they
give you a kind of a while it's
loading previously on Section a few
steps ahead that's why we're
here
I can't skip this in case you're
wondering oh well our loading screen has
a little bar now which is 3/4 full so at
least that's
something here we go let's get straight
in
hopefully
yeah all right so picks this up right
back at Mr Griffin which is pretty
good yeah thanks for the crossbow bro
thanks for the Memories gambling how
about that stop talking got it oh he
says the same thing great okay wish me
luck I'll try not to suck so hard this
time keep him
down yeah that's what's up I guess the
fire damage really freaks him the [__]
out actually
crossbow takes him down though about to
die I'm trying to [__] crossbow I
haven't got it equip do
I silly
Danny come at me bro that's what's
up flame on come
on here we go here we go now we're
making
money
uh-uh damn burn
[__] that's what's up all right
we're doing better
already come on take out your
crossbow it just slows down time a
little bit as
well um I'm going to use Thunderbolt on
this one come on circle around
I just hit him
here yeah that's what's
up all right so let's set him on fire oh
[__] I missed him I also didn't take him
down I think in the like the designated
area this is one of the only scripted
fights uh in the game apparently oh what
the [__] where's he
going oh yeah hey roach what's up our
Griffin's gone for a little run uh this
is scripted um I asked uh said they
project about this when I played this uh
before this is
um this whole part where he goes up to
the windmill it's like a two-tier battle
it's one of the only ones they do at uh
scripted uh monster Batts apparently um
it was just part of them trying to show
the dynamic nature of of fights in the
game H we
soon so hopefully this is evocative of
uh the rest of the battles in this game
all right
Griffin let's wrong crossbow got
Tong set on
fire chop him
up [__] getting
greedy getting bloodborne
greedy
[__]
die
yeah how you slay a monster right there
Beast of white Orchard
complete not bad not bad didn't even
have to eat any bread bro you could
stand to improve some
things like what for example upward
vertical strike it's too obvious but
more on that later take the Griffin's
head to the black ones already are
horses meet me at the
end all
right let's uh take this guy head and
then be done with it loot the
Griffin Griffin egg Griffin mutagen
Griffin
Trophy this is my favorite
part got to take a souvenir to the
occasion doesn't even look that
sharp now I got a nice little uh it's
like the medieval equivalent of a bobble
head on your card
dashboard this
little head H one of the things you
might have noticed there as well is we
picked up a
mutagen which can now be slaughtered
into into that little uh sorry I took
that one out by
accident oh it wants me to do the
tutorial
okay actually no take this
guy go over to the mutagens I got pop
this mutagen in there that gives me uh
50%
vitality and I can keep that with uh one
of those slots that's my little load out
there uh and that's the Witcher three
wild huntt that's uh all I'm going to
show for now this um aspect this part
next part of the game uh when I bring
back the the head basically finishes off
this prologue which has a little bit of
a story spoiler in it which there's no
real point in getting into uh right now
uh but that's uh
basically it this has
been uh games spot now playing of The
Witcher 3 wild Hunt thank you so much to
everyone for uh need to get a nice
Sunset there in the background there you
go uh thanks to everyone for for joining
us uh on today's stream we'll have
continuing coverage of course of The
Witcher 3 wal hunt including updated
reviews of the Xbox one and PlayStation
4 stuff coming out of Kevin vanard who's
got a a bunch of other interesting
features around the game coming up over
the next uh couple of days and obviously
after the game comes out as well next
Tuesday so thank you very much for
watching on gamespot.com uh also to the
folks who are over on the YouTube and
Twitch streaming channels or if you're
watching this on demand make sure you go
back to gamespot.com to read our 10 out
of 10 review of The Witcher 3 W hunt and
see our continuing coverage of the game
there thanks very much I'll see you next
time I
got and